suppose you say you've been making films
and screenwriting what 12 years new I've
been writing for over about 12 years and
I said I've been actively directing for
about for about four years now yeah so
you know it takes me a while to get to a
project because you know it's I had
certain visions and I see it in my head
and I really fight to get that you know
before I actually let it out so some
projects you know redemption was like a
year before I was able to get it out and
it was on you know just to fine-tune
fine tone and you know but I'm really
proud of it and that's that's my thing
is that the the end of the day when you
you do a project is you have to be proud
of what you've done at the end it's all
about perfection my hero no it's not
ready yeah so he has to have everything
perfect before he released some people
would he just do it out there anything
he was like nice and already is so this
I got a good at that so he takes his
time with a project which is good and
what I would say the new filmmakers is
that you know what I've learned from in
being so stubborn before saying no it's
not ready it's not ready it's not ready
every time I've done that I've always
learned something else that's pushed me
to a point where I'm like now it's ready
and it's like I learned something else
you know and uh that's something I think
you know I see a lot of other short
films that are you know from guys like
me similar in the same atmosphere and I
think part of the reasons why I have a
different leg up one and that different
understanding is because of my day job
and it's working you know with on a
peripheral side of scoring and seeing a
lot of the major Hollywood films before
they're finally you finished and I see a
lot of them is still in their rule forms
and I'm like wait a minute that looks
like mine and then it began to give me
more and more confidence that okay well
with the proper team with the proper
people who have the knowledge of what
they're doing in their craft like I do
Ave audio I could actually make a film
and that's when I started to really gain
they are the courage that I could do it
myself and stop just writing and started
directing because I I know what I'm
doing with audio but and it gave me the
confidence that I could meet people who
know what they're doing with lighting
know what
doing with cameras and they understand
the camera work and if different aspects
of it and luckily for me I did and you
know where I'm assembling a crew now
we're getting better and stronger with
every project and I'm looking forward to
see what we can you know do together in
the future
you